Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to our session on modernizing
clinical trial communications with AI.
My name's Julie Klam. I'm from the NCI Center for Biomedical Informatics
and Information Technology.
I'm really looking forward to this session today.
Before I introduce our panelists today, I just want to take a moment
and
as we talk about clinical trials, remind ourselves
that today, participating in clinical trials is still
far more difficult than it should be for patients.
For some patients, the challenge is geographic.
Trials are often concentrated at major academic centers that
require patients to travel long distances, sometimes across
states or even countries. And this can mean time off work,
arranging for childcare, and significant financial burden.
And for patients who are already navigating serious illness, these
barriers can be enough to make participation impossible.
But geography is only part of the story.
Even when a trial is accessible, understanding it can
be another hurdle entirely.
Consent forms are frequently long and technical, and written in a
language that assumes a high level of medical competency.
Patients may struggle to understand what
participation really means, including the
risks, the benefits and the alternatives.
And for those who aren't fluent in English, the barriers are even higher
with limited availability of high-quality translated
materials.
And these challenges don't just affect individual patients.
They shape who can really participate in research, and
ultimately, whose data informs the therapies we develop.
So that's why the work we're going to be discussing today is really important.
If we can use AI to make clinical trials more understandable,
more accessible, and more inclusive, we have an opportunity
not just to improve processes, but to expand
participation in a really meaningful and equitable way.
So with that, I want to introduce our panelists for today.
Let's see. Oh, sorry. Let's see.
Good.
Go where?
Go to Tana, Julie.
Oh, thank you.
So go to back.
Oh, can you help me bring up the slides again? Sorry.
There you go. Just go to Tana.
Oh, here we go. Go to...
Yeah.
Okay.
Start.
Perfect.
Thank you. Sorry about that.
So to introduce our panelists today,
I'll be moderating today's session, and our first speaker
then will be Umut Topaloglu.
Umut is the chief of the Clinical and Translational Informatics branch at the
NCI Center for Biomedical Informatics and IT.
And next, Tana Nelson will be speaking.
Tana is a clinical research and informatics specialist at CBIIT.
And finally, we'll hear from James Gulley.
James is the co-director for the Center for Immuno-Oncology, and he's the
clinical director of the National Cancer Institute.
Here are our disclosures. And so I'd like to welcome Umut
Topaloglu.
Thanks, Julie. Hello, everyone. Good afternoon.
Thanks for being here.
As you may agree, clinical research is under a lot of pressure
from multiple directions, increasing protocol
complexities, massively fragmented data silos, and
critical human bottlenecks that's costly and rare to find,
slow everything down. So these aren't isolated
problems, but they compound each other.
Having said that, AI offers a real path forward, accelerating
timelines for some of the repeated tasks.
It can read and understand unstructured
data more than it can in the past, and it could
reduce some of the administrative burden.
But what we learned is dropping AI into a broken or
unsupported environment doesn't fix the problem.
It just automates the chaos.
This is why our core principle from start is
augmentation, not replacement. Every tool we built
is designed around preserving expert oversight while
scaling
capabilities. What I will talk now is
portfolio of AI applications, each one technically promising,
but as Tana next will explain, the technical solution is
only part of the story.
What makes any of them actually work is the environment we
are going to build around it and
keeping humans in the loop.
Our team at CTRIB
organized AI strategy around four interconnected
pillars: semantic infrastructure, real-world data, precision medicine,
and RT. Together, they span the full trial life
cycle.
So what is important to notice is that these aren't standalone
tools. They form an ecosystem, and
like any ecosystem, each component depends on health
of the others. Semantic infrastructure is needed for
matching to work, and trial matching is needed for precision medicine
to work.
That interdependence is exactly why a supporting
environment
matters so much. You can't just build an AI
layer.We have to build the connective tissue around
that, such as governance standards, workflows, and human
checkpoint.
So let me talk about an example tool that we have
been focusing that is semi-automatic annotating data elements.
A foundational challenge across all of the work is that the data
elements collected across studies can't be compared or
combined because they lack the standardized
representation and definitions such as common data elements.
This is a data environment problem as much as a technical one.
One solution that we have been piloting is
semi-automatically match new data elements to existing
CDEs
using semantic similarity, permissible values, alignment,
and rule-based filtering. But as you may noticed,
we put human in the middle as number four here.
And before any match is accepted, human reviewers accept,
rejects, or send it back for comparison.
This isn't an afterthought, and it's
a load-bearing step. When a confidence is low,
like in step number five,
MicroRec layers surfaces a side-by-side comparison with
plain
language explanation of similarities and risks.
This is a work of example of what we mean by supporting environment,
a structured workflow, confidence scoring, and audit trail and
clear human decision point. The AI
accelerates and human certifies.
Going a
step
higher, we have been also developing a fair data workbench to
address one of the most structured problem in cancer research,
data collected in silos with inconsistent
formats, missing dictionaries, and no common standard.
Therefore, cross-trial analysis effectively blocked without
solving this step. So we have been developing a 12-step
pipeline, a modular one, as you can see on the right bottom corner.
Each of them serves different purpose, and with the
modular approach or architecture, we'll be able to not
only follow audit these, but use the
tools like the semantic annotation that I mentioned previously.
Moving into the real-world data,
as you may agree that the clinical data in
EHR
needs to improve the data quality.
Therefore, our team has been working with our colleagues at ONC,
FDA, CMS, and CDC to develop the USCDI Plus cancer data
standards. So can we address collection of the
data within EHR? That's an ongoing work, but we
also have been developing FHIR data quality
ontology,
so we can quantify the data quality with the published
literature, and we have been developing some testing pipelines
with Inferno.
Important point to make is to LLMs are needed
to help some of the unstructured data within EHRs,
and we have some foundation model work related to those
that we are going to briefly mention tomorrow's session.
On the right side, we are working with our
CCCT office, Center for
Cancer Clinical Trials,
CTRP program, developing
tools, LLM-assisted tools to structure eligibility
criteria.
As you have seen on the screen, our goal is to approach
problem from the two ends. One is, if we are
able to structure the eligibility criteria for cancer trials
and structure
patient data from EHR, we will be able to go
criteria by criteria, as you can see on the right corner,
why LLMs are making decision that they are making instead of
just one patient is eligible or not.
I think this is important to become a
functioning clinical decision support system.
Another example that I would like to mention is the
MatchBox, which is NCI's platform for the MATCH
trial. Currently, it supports
MyeloMATCH and ComboMATCH
studies and assign patients to the treatment arms based on their
tumor molecular profile.
This flow on the top is the current deterministic workflow of
PME is the patient matching engine, and it follows the rules
engine. We are
in early stages of pilot to utilize the
eligibility criteria I mentioned on the previous screen.
Can we use MCPs and other matching tools to
match patients to studies to streamline the
process?
And as you can see at the bottom, there are two
verification by human steps purposely
designed. Initial humans review, and there is a verification
committees who has to sign off for any
assignment.
This is the way we are thinking how AI could
help. These are during the protocol life cycle.
And I'm going to turn over to Tena, who will speak some examples of
these.
Tena?
Okay. So, this slide, this is how
we represent the roadmap that we're looking for into the
future. So this particular
Roadmap is based on the ARTIE initiative, AI for Research or
Translational Informatics. And what you see here
are areas where we've identified we could
use technology to modernize certain
operations within these areas. And so you can see many of the
topics here relate to the study teams and how they develop
their protocols and how they start
conducting their protocols even through study closeout and then data
sharing. But an important piece to note on here is the patient
aspect, and you see that down at the bottom, where we are also
developing tools that help patients,
once they're diagnosed, to help identify trials that they may
qualify for, and then referring those patients to the right study
teams, and then also providing an educational feature
that uses more modern techniques,
such as creating podcasts and videos about a
specific study to help them better understand
what's going to happen during the study.
And then also in the language that they're most comfortable
with, so providing multiple options for them to learn about their study other
than just sitting with a study team and reading a consent document.
So one important thing I want to cover here is
how we approach
developing solutions that involve AI within this
clinical trials ecosystem. And so
these are the guiding principles that we use.
So first, we want to protect from any unsafe or ineffective
systems. So we do not want to create any
system that causes harm or actually creates more burden or
more work for the study teams. That is an ineffective system.
So we are really focused on not doing that.
We want to focus on efficiency. We also want to
calibrate the kinds of
AI that we're using to accomplish a task.
So depending on what the problem is,
we first really understand that problem very
deeply and then determine what AI system or how
to develop the AI to use for that particular problem instead
of finding an AI tool and trying
to fit it into a problem that exists.
So we start with the problem, find the solution instead of have the
solution in search of a problem.
And we also want to prevent any kind of
algorithmic discrimination. So we design
for equity and accessibility from the start.
And that goes for the patients that we serve, but it also
applies to the study teams. So we want to make sure that any tools
we develop at the NCI are available to
the research community as a whole.
So we don't want to keep these just internally to NIH or NCI.
We want to share them.
And also safeguarding privacy. So
the data that we use stays where it
belongs. We don't want to pull that data out into other systems
and risk any sort of cybersecurity issues.
So where possible, the data does not move.
So a clinical repository with data, the data stays there and we
bring the AI to it and
prompt the
AIs on that particular data,
but we don't move the data around.
And then we also want to declare when we're using AI.
We want to make sure that the patient is aware and the study teams are aware
when AI is in use and then offer an alternative
when possible. So people have a choice on whether they want to use the AI system
we've developed, and they know when they're being
exposed to an AI system.
So clinical research for cancer patients
is done-- These patients are in a vulnerable state.
They've just been diagnosed with cancer.
They're struggling with long-term, potentially
life-taking conditions. And
we really
want to make sure that they comprehend what
is going on within the trial.
So it's not enough just to disclose the risks.
And we use often lengthy, jargon-heavy documents
to convey what's going to happen in a study, and it can often
be overwhelming for patients. And so we
really need to use a concise, plain language consent form
that improves actual comprehension which is the ethical
standard.
And we want to maintain the patient's autonomy
through this process. And really that includes
making readable, streamlined documents for the patient to read and
understand and reduce the cognitive burden that the patient is
feeling going through, first of all, dealing with the condition and then
finding a study for them to join.
And participants'
health literacy varies widely.
So with education, language
proficiency, so we're trying to create tools that will
accommodate different health literacy levels and also
languages.
And overly complex or long documents can appear opaque or
even evasive.
And that really undermines the trust that we're trying to
have with the patient.
And so these are the key issues that we're looking to solve with some of
these examples that I'm going to show you here
shortly.So,
the first example, this is related to the consent document.
So,
as you all know, protocol documents can be over 100
pages. They can be very long, very technical.
And so what we've done is to take
the protocol document and develop a
consent form from the content of the protocol document.
And what you see here on the screen first is a disclaimer for the
consent form. So we want the study teams to
know this is AI-generated, and this is ready for human
review and refinement. It is not intended to go directly to
the IRB for approval. It is intended to be a first
draft only.
So when we get into the body of the consent document,
so we use the NIH Clinical Center consent
document as a template to start.
So you can see that the headers on the document are preserved,
and then all the information here is in this particular consent
document is at an eighth-grade reading level.
And we've included, you can see there on the right-hand side, what
you see there is OHSRP, Office of Human Subject Research
Protections
guidance. So as the study teams go through
and review the consent document, there's guidance
directly from the OHSRP so they can review the information
and make decisions on what they need to change or what they don't
particularly care for
that the AI generated so that they can have a good
representation of their study.
So the other thing I wanted to point out here is
that we pull from a
procedure library. So at NIH, we have a procedure
library with layperson descriptions.
And so instead of having AI generate every single aspect of
the document, we rely on a repository of
information that is approved by NIH, and we'll pull that information into
the consent form as well.
And then here you'll see
we bring in the
risks for any study drugs, and it's in a very
structured
organization here. So you'll have the
common
side effects, the occasional side effects, and then the rare side effects.
So we pull that in in a structured way.
And all of this comes from the
protocol document.
And then areas where
in our analysis, we've determined that AI does not
do a great job in determining certain aspects of
what should be in the
consent document and what shouldn't.
We also bring in more inline comments here so that
the study teams know where they need to make a decision about
which blocks of text should be included or
excluded. So in this particular case, the storage,
sharing, and future research using specimens and data.
When we were developing the AI model to
identify this particular piece from a protocol, it really had a
difficult time. And so instead of holding up or
releasing the tool to the study teams, we went
ahead and just added in those inline comments so the study teams could
determine which sections to include and not include.
And again, this is intended to be a first draft, not the
final version. There are pieces here and there that
may not be great, but we retain required language
where possible. Where it's required, legal language is retained as
well, so we don't have AI generate those pieces of the
consent document. And then there are other areas where we, in the
descriptions of the studies and what will happen, we use AI
generation.
So we also, while we were at it,
since we have the protocol, we developed this layperson summary.
It's a one-page document. We adapted this template from
a template that was developed at Wash U and
just kind of made it our own. And so what you see here is a
one-page document that gives a layperson's
title for the study,
the principal investigator,
the institute or center, and then eight panes of
information starting with what the goal of the study is,
who can be in the study, what will happen during the study,
how long the participant will be in the study, the
high-level risks, and then the benefits.
We also want to make sure and talk about
the voluntariness of being in the study and how they
would withdraw from the study or any alternatives that the patient
could potentially
take advantage of, and then any costs or payments that would be
provided to the patient. So, and then at the bottom, some contact
information, so if the patient wanted to join the study, they could or get more
information about the study. And you can see this is very high level.
Very high level. And that's really intended to be that way so patients
can just get an idea of what the study is about before they jump
into the long consent document.
Another thing that we're working on is AI language
translation, and this is
sort of a new development in the last couple of months
that we're working on. But what we're doing here,
we're doing this because the demand for multilingual
consent or even documents in general
isin higher demand than we've ever had in the
past. And so really, since human translation is the gold
standard, the problem is that there
often aren't enough humans to keep up with the demand.
And so we
brought a language translator onto our team,
and we're working with her using AI-generated
documents, and we're starting with consent forms.
And the early results are promising.
So in industry, typically a human translator,
they can translate about 2,000 words per
day of complex scientific language.
And so a 10,000-word consent document can take up
to five days to translate. And so with AI
generation in our early tests,
we can cut that time in half, so about two and a half days
with an AI-translated document that the human goes
in and compares to the English version, makes
modifications, and then eventually certifies per
regulatory requirements, and then the study teams can submit that
to the IRB for approval. So
even though we're using AI translation, we
still have a human reviewing that and a human expert in
the language that we're translating, which right now is just Spanish.
And then we're providing the certification document and the translated
document to the IRB.
So
really the question isn't whether to use AI to translate,
but how we can do translation in a more sustainable
way. And so our approach here, I've kind of gone over
the approach here, is to generate the initial
translation.
We are also developing some analysis tools about the
translation quality, and we have 10 metrics that we're measuring
against. And then using LLM as a
judge, so we're having one LLM evaluate
a second LLM,
or the translation LLM to determine where we might can make
some
natural flow, those kinds of language
improvements. And then we have the in-house translator as well, that when
she makes those modifications to the document, we have those
modifications. So we've got three great documents that we
can now analyze to see how can we fine-tune
and train these LLMs to improve their translations over
time. So again, we're in early
stages here, but we have some promising results here
for
the translation.
So in conclusion, really we are-- Well, for my
part conclusion,
these three tools that we talked about today, every tool produces
an editable output. So none of this is final.
And we send these documents to the experts to have
them review for final submission.
The language translator can open, modify, and
make changes, and the study teams can take those documents and
modify them, and then they own the content.
The regulatory language is preserved in these documents where necessary,
and readability standards are met, which can be very
difficult for study teams to do manually.
Each tool is designed to align with the ethics committee requirements,
drawing from established guidelines, and templates where possible.
And the outputs really are first drafts, as I've said
before, and designed to give the experts a strong
compliant starting point and reduce time spent on the
hardest parts of document development.
And I'm going to hand it over to Dr. Gulley
to round us out here.
Well, thank you so much, Tana. So I'm going to talk a little
bit-- So we've heard a little bit about the what and the how, but I'm going to
talk a little bit about the why in just a few minutes here before we
get into the panel, which is hopefully going to be the most fun part.
So you already heard from Dr. Clem about
the patient experience, which clearly that must be paramount and
really the most important reason.
But I think another key reason why
is the impact on the clinical team.
So first of all, I just have to
mention that the clinicians and the investigators, they're
under a lot of sustained strain.
The workload demands, the administrative burden, the
growing complexity of care.
And clinical trials, while they are absolutely
vital to progress, really add to this burden.
The protocol demands, the documentation, the regulatory,
the coordination across many systems that
rarely communicate seamlessly with each other.
And clinical trial timelines are very long,
unfortunately, and they're slowed by processes that are manual,
duplicative, and fragmented.
So investigators spend an increasing
amount of time on unglamorous tasks that are necessary
and perhaps could be facilitated by AI tools.
The combination of high cognitive load, administrative
overhead, and prolonged timeline has real
consequences.
This limits the number of trials that can open, it slows accrual,
and it also constrains the pace
of clinical research progress overall.So
LLMs can perform a variety of different tasks by
reducing the friction in the system.
They don't just
take the human out of the loop. They don't.
They keep the human there, but they can definitely decrease
the friction.
Some examples are
to structure and summarize clinical information, to
generate first drafts, as you heard about from Tana, to support
communication with teams and patients.
Really, this is just all to offload the
cognitive work and to standardize processes, and
also to decrease cycle times.
So even modest efficiency gains can be
compounded. But this is not just about
convenience. It's really to reallocate
time for the investigator, time that they can
have for higher value activities like clinical decision
making, like patient engagement, and like scientific
insights.
So
all the while, it can make the clinical trial
system more scalable.
So, and we at your NCI want to
make these tools available widely for everyone.
So
if we think about the accessibility from the patient standpoint
and the sustainability from the standpoint of the investigator,
I think you come to the conclusion that we
really have to avoid unnecessary
complexity. So as we think about this in the panel,
I think we want to talk about how we can use AI
tools potentially to safely,
reliably
move the needle if we can.
And I'm going to turn this back over to Dr. Klamp.
Thanks, Dr. Golianoff, for those comments and summary
of what we've been doing at the NCI to facilitate
opening clinical trials. So for the rest of our time together, we want
to open it up to questions from the audience and to engage the
panel in a discussion.
And
maybe I could start by
asking the first question.
I'd like to ask,
what's the biggest misconception you encounter when you tell
colleagues that you're using AI in clinical trial
operations?
Dr. Golianoff, maybe we'll start with you.
Yeah. So great question. So I think a lot of times people
think, "Well, okay, you're going to use AI.
Well, what is my role?" I think
that people often think that you're going to be replacing
somebody's job.
I think really what we're trying to say here is we're not trying to replace
anybody's job. We're just trying to help them have tools to do it more
efficiently. And if we can greatly accelerate
the
pre-approval timelines, the clinical trial writing
process
all the way through, and the post-approval timelines, if we can get patients
enrolled on studies more quickly, we can accelerate the time where
we can get
the data needed to make progress. And that's what
we're all about. So this is not about replacing
people, it's about helping people do their job more effectively.
Great.
Other comments?
I was going to add to that. So that's a very good point that we hear
a lot. And the other thing is that there's so much
hype in the media about AI, and people
are afraid that we are being careless
about the development or how we're incorporating AI into
clinical research. And so that is another thing that I think is,
we try to be very clear about how
conscientious we're being when we evaluate a
process and determine that AI would be a good fit.
And so we always try to make sure that we get
past the hype and get down to the reality of how AI
can improve our processes.
Thanks. Maybe a kind of a follow-on question.
We're talking about what's the relationship between the human and the AI.
So in all three talks, you've really emphasized human
oversight throughout. So in practice,
what does that really look like? Who are the humans in the
loop, and what are they reviewing for?
Umut, do you want to start?
Sure.
I think as we are thinking about these processes, and
as you can see on the screen, the 12 months to open, there are a lot of people
involved in that process. And from the
study initiation teams,
budget discussions, there are a lot of contractual discussions.
There are a lot of people involved, and some of them very hard to
train or very hard to find. And can we identify
areas as
we are trying to use these tools as an augmentation layer, not a
replacement?
Can we have user-friendly tools and workflows for
them to involve? I think Tana has given a great example
that they need to accept or edit for consent translation, for
instance. That's probably a good model.
When we are showing some of the automated or semi-automated manner
of the
common data elements, can we have the
humans
quickly looking over and accepting
or rejecting or modifying the output?
I think those are important, and pretty much as you may
agreeAI tools are great if the humans
can easily take a look at and validate the output.
I think there's a common consensus around is that, I don't know, Tana, if you
want to add anything.
Yeah. And one key thing about who those humans are
in the loop,
it's always good to have a human in the loop, but it's better to have
a good human in the loop, or the person who is the expert in that
particular area. So for language translation, it's
a medical translator who really knows
medical translation in the language that we're translating.
For consent documents, it's the study team, the people who wrote the protocol
themselves. The expert is very specific to what the task
is, and so we want to identify who those experts are and
make sure that they stay within the
whatever we've developed, whatever tool we've developed, and keep them in the loop.
Yeah. Anything to add to that?
No, I think that's good.
Please come to the mics if you want to-
Yeah
... ask questions. Yeah. Thank you.
So I had a couple of questions follow up on what Tana
had presented. So one of my questions was, so you're
starting with Spanish, and you've got a person
double-checking the translation and making sure it's perfect at the end.
I'm curious for other languages in the future.
Would this be a just-in-time kind of thing where you might
ask the AI to translate it when there's a particular
need for a particular language?
Or is this something that you would do ahead of time and just maybe
the most 10 common languages, just kind of have those ready to go, and
then get that human in the loop again, kind of just in time.
I'm curious. And then also a follow-up question to that
is,
do you think that it will ever get to the point where we could use
just the AI for that?
That's a-
Great questions
... this is a good question for Dr. Goli to answer since you have...
But I'll
say my answer first. So we're starting with Spanish just because
80% of the consent documents that we need are in
Spanish. But yes, we would like to expand to other
languages. It
can get difficult to have
people, experts in all of the language on
staff to do the certification of the documents.
And so we are trying to stream that a little bit.
I'll admittedly say we don't exactly know how this
is going to turn out
in the future as
a pipeline for doing this work. But we're trying to demonstrate that,
yes, AI really does have a place in this area
and
develop a process for using AI that can be
trustworthy. And I'm going to let James answer the rest of that.
Yeah. So first, a little preface. So
when
talking with patients and with communicating about clinical trials, I think
building trust is really important and understanding, truly understanding is really
important, as Tana mentioned. And so we always ask them what their language
preference is for medical terminology, and if it happens to be a different
language, then we
go ahead and do the translation. So
I envision a day when we will be able to do just-in-time
translations for any
language.
We are not there yet.
However,
to me, it's not a matter of if this will happen, it's a matter of when it will
happen. And I do think that what we're doing right
now is we're finding out what works and what doesn't.
We're refining models. We're going iteratively.
We're finding, we're catching things.
Actually, the large language models can actually catch things that the
interpreter gets wrong. And that can be helpful too because the
IRB may not know that, and these are people that are qualified and...
So
I think this is an iterative process right now, but I do think that
we will be able to get to a place where I'm hoping
we'll have enough data that we can
satisfy the regulatory experts and say, "This is going to be
just as good. We make
as few or fewer mistakes than the interpreter
does."
If I may add to that. As you may know, some
models speak 62 languages like their
mother tongue. That's a power. Think
about people coming to clinic needing some help understanding what that
study is about. That's a very powerful tool.
To answer if those models are going to take humans out, I
don't think with the current structure it is possible.
We need to have
the,
how can I say, AIs to do the repeated task as much as possible by
these models. But the current structure of these transformers, I don't
think it's there, and not sure if there will be
anytime soon.
The other quick thing, I'm sorry, I just want to say is that
about 80% of our translations are in Spanish. So that...
Got it. Yeah, I guess I was just kind of envisioning
the other 20%. There's probably a
very small population of some
language that just-
Lots of different ones
... I'm just wondering if it's better to have an AI translation of that than
none.
Mm-hmm.
Right. That's, yeah.
Oh, yeah. And I'll say too, to your point about
doing these the top 10 translations automatically
for every protocol, and we have thought about that too, because we can do them
at a fraction of the price than the
traditional translation. There are still costs because you
still have humans,
and you still have the costs from using the LLMs, but it really is a
fraction of the cost of using the traditional method.
So, it would be good to just, when we get a protocol,
here are the top 10 languages, and if you need an additional language
We can do that translation. So, yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks.
As I was looking at this, what I was thinking, not just as this is making it easier
for patients, but it reduces the barriers for sites to be able to participate.
Yes.
As you're
user testing the tools, are you able to engage clinics that
might have otherwise said, "No, I can't take this on," so
that you actually can access bigger populations by
making the site onboarding so much easier and the site
ops so much easier?
So
let me
say that that is a fantastic question. I didn't pay you.
But I will say that,
yes, I imagine a future where we can decrease the
barriers to
clinical trials. So the issues are you have
your busy practicing oncologist in Macon, Georgia, who
is seeing dozens of patients a day
and really doesn't have time to
be getting into clinical trials, understand what's going on,
and enrolling a patient in a clinical trial.
And
yet he has that patient there that really wants to stay with him or
her because they've built that trust
over a long period of time,
and they were there at the diagnosis, et cetera.
What if we could make it so that the
electronic case report forms automatically pull data from the
ECR app, the HR, and you can
make that easy. He doesn't have to, or she doesn't have to enter that data in.
What if you could do this in a way where you could have teams that could
have a Zoom meeting with the patient and say,
"Here's the consent. Here's how we would go
about this," and answer questions.
And
what if we could make it so that patient could just stay there?
I think there are opportunities here.
I think that we have tools right now that we could utilize in this
manner, but I think that we're still working on getting
structured data from the electronic healthcare record is
more straightforward. Unstructured data is less straightforward, and
so I think we and others are still working on that aspect.
But yes, that is exactly where we want to go.
If I may add to that, I think another aspect of our work to
utilizing some industry standards, so
ideally, cancer centers health system could take these
solutions that we would like to make it open.
Maybe pharma colleagues who are interested
in the new studies, they could utilize the same standard
infrastructure to make it easier for the health systems.
That will be the ultimate benefit to the patients.
And I think that
we could increase the proportion of adult patients who are
going into clinical trials from less than 10% to
a lot higher than that. And we could get our answers quicker,
and that is going to help the whole field.
Thank you. Great presentation.
I have one quick question, and I have a real question after that.
My quick question is , did you use AI to generate all your
illustrations on your slides?
My three slides, yes, I did.
Awesome.
And I asked it to take into account the AACR
colors.
That's great.
So my real question is on...
This is essentially a new technology that we're introducing, and every new
technology you have to do a risk, a reward, a
risk-benefit analysis. So you've obviously discussed the benefits, but on
the risk side, which we also heard some of,
it often is to do with humans not understanding the
technology correctly and maybe using it incorrectly in some ways,
or
not intentionally, maybe unintentionally, just because they don't know better.
So I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about what you...
I'm envisioning or seeing in my head right now,
standing in the clinical center and all your clinician colleagues
around, and they have to use this technology.
Yeah.
And how are you going to go about making sure that they get the appropriate
education and training, that they know how to use these technologies?
Let me take on this. I think
some of the examples that we have shown that the decision
making shouldn't be purely on the LLM or AI model that you are using.
For instance, the clinical trial matching example, our goal
is to structure the eligibility criteria and as much
standardize the data in the EHR, so LLMs can do the
matching. And having an interpretability layer where you'll be able to
see each of those. Instead of making decision
themselves, they facilitate. I think that's the approach we have been
taking. Another one on the annotating the
CDEs, the humans will see the
CDEs that is close. So as much
possible, avoiding the risk by making
sure humans are the one the decision is made.
Of course, there is this risk of over-reliance of the AI after seeing
500 translation being done perfectly, you
may think, but that's an ongoing issue in the comment, of course.
But
again, trying to avoid LLMs to make the
decision, rather be a helpful assistant augments.
And I would just add to that, absolutely education's going to be important for the
clinician.
But I think that when they understand that this is a
tool that could help them, that
could not replace what they are doing, and certainly not replace
their decision-making, but it could help them get to that decision more
quickly. I think that that's going to be where we see an
acceleration of efficiencies. And
I do think thatRelieving the cognitive burden of
repetitive tasks is going to then allow that
physician or
other healthcare provider to say, "You know what?
This is going to open up so many other things for me.
Let me think about this very carefully." And hopefully,
they get that balance of
still having to be involved and engaged, but yet not having to
do all of these
unglamorous tasks that we have to do every day.
Thank you.
And I'll also say, what we're trying to develop are
tools where the study teams or whomever is
using the system can get in and get out.
We don't want them to be unnecessarily burdened by a
complicated user interface or any
tasks where
it's not really intuitive to them as to what's happening and
what to do next. And so we try to create these very simple,
clean
tools for them to use for a very specific
need so they can get out and get on with their day.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Thank you very much. Very great
panel and discussion. I would like to ask two questions.
One is about the deployment.
As we know, we would like to have the deployment to reflect the
workflow, and then we would know how it improve and
save time, and
improve efficiency.
Do we have any
data, or do we collect information from the
research nurses and clinicians and patients
to
teach us? Does that tool work with you?
That's my first question. And my second question, before I forget.
My second question is about the consent form is
a great communication from our research team to
the participant.
Do we consider
expand our AI tool to generate patient
education materials to help them to understand the
study, which the consent form has limited
pages, and the patients need time to digest
the research
purpose, risks, and what reflects to their life.
Thank you very much.
So I'll start. So
for the first question--
Wait, repeat your first question just to make sure.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Yes. So what we did is
we engaged with study teams directly.
There are many teams across the NIH who are willing to give us
their protocols, have us generate the consent
documents. We sent it back to them and got
real-time feedback from them. Good, bad, and ugly, we wanted it
all. So we knew what we were doing well, what we were not
doing well, and what we needed to improve.
So it was an informal setting like that where we, one
by one, went through, got feedback from them.
And they would annotate their consent documents and say what they liked and what
they didn't like and how they wanted it differently.
So we do have that information. But as we roll this out, we've
rolled it out to the entire NIH for people to use.
We're developing a survey for them to fill out,
a voluntary survey. If they want to provide us feedback, they can.
Otherwise, they don't necessarily have to.
I've been meeting in person with some study teams so that I can get a
better idea for longer conversations about what they like and
don't like as well and have gotten some really good feedback from there.
So to your point about the patient education, we do have
plans to develop
podcast material,
AI-generated videos, and even provide for the procedures
that patients are going to have that are listed in that consent document,
provide links to what those procedures are so they can see what
does a CT scan look like, what happens in an MRI, and so they
can get a better idea of what they're going to see and what they're going
to experience before they actually get to the
research site. So yes, we have all of those in
development.
Nothing to show yet, but we are considering that. Yeah.
And just to add to that a little bit.
So some of the metrics that
we're capturing, how we're doing it now, and then how we're doing it with AI, and
then how we're refining that process, we're capturing all of that,
and it really is cutting down time substantially.
So the time to first draft for a consent form can be
up to two weeks for a medical writer to go through all the
different parts of a--
Usually they're on the study team and they're writing that.
And it usually ends up with a
readability level that is not adequate.
And so then it's further refinement after that.
And then this, you can just upload the protocol and four minutes
later you have your first draft. So it's pretty nice.
I have also seen some study teams, they will submit their
protocol, get the
consent draft, and then they have developed
bits and pieces on their own, so they take parts
and leave other parts. So they still have the option to take what they
want and leave what they don't want.
So it just gives more options to the study teams on how to-
Yeah
... how to word things and how to describe things.
And right now, when Tana said that this is available for all of the
NIH, it's in the intramural program right now.
Intramural, yes.
But we hope to be able to make this available to other sites
extramurally, so across the US, et cetera.
And while
The template will be different for each institution.
That is something that's going to be open source so that
everyone can figure out exactly what template, and they can use their template.
And we're hoping to make this available soon.
Thank you. Thank you for the great work you do for us and
show a pilot the result and cutting the
burden to
participant and the research team. Thank you.
Thanks. And we do hope, I know these may seem like
small improvements. We start with the consent form and
move to the translation, but we're hoping as we
develop additional use cases for
AI to streamline these processes, that the
gains really compound upon each other to
really make a much more efficient trials process.
So, thanks.
Bob.
Is there time?
Yeah, I think we have time for one more question.
Excellent. Thank you very much. Bob Freeman with Mayo Clinic. Wonderful panel.
This is really exciting to see what you all are doing.
And I've got lots of things that I'd like to ask you about, but I think what I'll
do just in the last couple of minutes here is ask you,
as you've been thinking about this holistically, if we take a higher level view,
can you comment a little bit on how you envision AI not just
accelerating the existing workflow and process, but fundamentally
altering it?
The examples, and I really appreciated this because I'm a data guy, and I
think about the examples from the start of this panel through
the end. We heard about how humans can create
CDEs to help computers talk better to each other.
We heard about how AI is helping humans communicate to humans
better.
I'm curious, how can we get in front of this?
How do we avoid a situation where we're using AI to generate content
that we pass over to somebody else who uses AI to summarize that content
because it's just too much, right?
How can we use the AI-generated
protocols or AI-drafted protocols that are coming out of the
clinical trials and proactively
map the data that should be collected to the CDEs so it's
interoperable from the start?
Yes.
How do we change the way we're thinking about this? I'd love to hear your thoughts.
We didn't plan to you as well, so thanks for this great question.
So as you mentioned, the environment that we are trying to set
up to make sure these tools and approaches are successful,
yes, you can use a great AI translation
tool. Great, the consents are translated well, but how about the
other problems, right? So since then, we are looking this as an
ecosystem to see creating protocols in a structured
manner
and including the case report forms with
these common data elements. That's the part of the...
That was the reason I've shown that slide.
How we can make those enabled map to CDEs,
then going back to your CDI+ cancer, where we'll be able
to
map the terminology bindings of the FHIR data coming out of EHR to
those CRF. That's our vision. Of course, since it's too
early, we weren't able to share much.
But yes, exactly, we would like to make sure this life
cycle
are very connected with these tools helping humans so they can
see these tools are helping them, their life much easier,
faster, so they can accept and don't see this as a
threat. So yeah, exactly. That's ultimately going
to expedite a lot of things.
I'd love to follow up with you on that.
And yeah, just to add a little bit to that, Bob.
Thank you so much for the question.
And,
I think that in addition, our current
process, we often make the eCRF,
and then we find out, "Oh, we forgot something." This can allow us to look at the
consistency and be iterative, and the
first draft can be a lot better probably than our
second draft now.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah. And I'll say, I'll just add, too, that
the traditional way of writing protocols is
changing. So we're developing and like Umit said, we
can't really...
Maybe for next year's conference, developing a data-driven
protocol design
system where instead of having the
traditional Word documents and then people
here doing manual abstraction of
all the important features of the protocol itself, and this
whole team of people doing that, and then another team of people
creating the eCRFs. It's just this army of people who
are taking this Word document. So we're going straight to the source.
What can we do to create a more digital
protocol so that those elements of pulling out
the most important aspects of the protocol that are required for
reporting, eCRF creation, those things are already
structured and mapped.
That's wonderful.
Yeah.
Just one comment, and then I will yield.
As you're doing that, please think about the electronic inclusion/exclusion
criteria-
Yes
... so the phenotyping is easier.
Yes.
Thank you.
100%.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that was an excellent way to wrap up for today.
I'm sorry that we're out of time. I hope maybe some of our panelists will be
available to chat afterwards for any additional questions.
So thank you all for joining, and thanks again to our panelists.